Poly-
-mer.
Polymer!
[music]
What all Polymers are, are long-chain molecules.
Every polymer is some kind of a long-chain molecule.
[music]
Many mers together, and now we're a polymer.
The ability to bear stress -- that makes it useful as a clothing
fiber, for example.
-- Or, the ability to entangle, to give it rubbery properties, which
makes it useful as your shoe sole.
All of those things come from the long-chain nature.
And so, once you begin to understand that, you begin see what
makes polymers special.
Poly-
-mer.
[laughs]
[music]
This is a polymeric liquid, so if you apply sheer force slowly,
it will flow as a liquid.
Whereas, if you apply sheer force quickly, the chains will
entangle, and it will behave as a solid.
Rubber bands are made out of a polymer.
When it gets really cold, these chains, they can't slide
past each other anymore.
They're locked in place.
[children exclaim]
Slime!
There are polymers in diapers.
The natural proteins -- DNA is a polymer.
We eat polymers.
I've had Silly Putty before, which is a polymer.
My favorite polymer?
I will say Silly Putty.
That's what Silly Putty is. Silly Putty is a collection of polymer chains.
They're tangled up.
They're entangled with each other.
... A chain of molecules that are chained chemically,
and that can hold a certain amount of fluids.
A polymer is a long molecule of repeating parts.
Polymer.
[laughs]
[music]
Poly- whoo!
[laughs]
[music]